[Musik]
top 30 deutsche werben
die 30 häufigsten werben in deutschen
texten
die 30 häufigsten werden in deutschen
welches web ist auf nummer eins was
denkst du
welches werk ist auf nummer eins was
er halten erhalten
ich erhalte ich erhielt ich habe
erhalten
ich erhalte gerade einen telefonanruf
ich erhalte gerade ein telefonanruf
hallo ich kann jetzt nicht telefonieren
hallo ich kann jetzt wirklich nicht
telefonieren
bringen bringen
ich bringe ich brachte
ich habe gebracht ich bringe ich brachte
ich habe gebracht
ich bringe dem lehrer ein geschenk als
entschuldigung
ich springe
dem lehrer ein geschenk als
entschuldigung
halten halten
ich habe
ich hielt ich habe gehalten
ich halte ich hielt ich habe gehalten
ich halte einen stift in meiner hand
erklären erklären
[Musik]
ich erkläre ich erklärte ich habe
erklärt
ich erkläre euch heute die häufigsten
werben
heißen heißen
ich heiße ich hieß ich habe geheißen
ich heiße wurm
dürfen dürfen
ich darf ich durfte ich habe gedurft
ich darf heute ein eis essen
hörend hören
[Musik]
ich höre ich hörte ich habe gehört ich
höre ich hörte ich habe gehört
ich höre musik während dem unterricht
ich höre musik während im unterricht
zeigen zeigen
ich zeige ich zeigte ich habe gezeigt
ich zeige ihm meinen lieblingsort
[Musik]
nehmen nehmen
ich nehme ich nahm ich habe genommen
ich nehme ein bad
liegen liegen
ich liege ich lag ich habe gelegen
ich liege auf dem bett
thun thun
ich tue ich tat
ich habe getan ich tue ich tat ich habe
getan
ich habe es getan
ich habe
das getan
bleiben bleiben
ich bleibe ich blieb ich bin geblieben
wer bleiben trotz
ende
wir bleiben trotzdem freunde
fragen fragen
ich frage ich fragte ich habe gefragt
ich fragte sie nach dem weg
ich frage
dass sie nach dem weg
wie komme ich zur insel
wie komme ich zu ende wer kaum ein
echter ende
finden finden
ich finde ich fand ich habe gefunden
ich habe gestern den schatz gefunden
wissen wissen
ich weiß ich wusste ich habe gewusst ich
weiß ich wusste ich habe gewusst
ich weiß welches werk auf nummer eins
ist
ich weiß welches werbe auf nummer eins
weißt du es auch
stehen stehen
ich stehe ich stand ich habe gestanden
ich stehe auf dem tisch
ich stehe
auf dem tisch
und ich steh auf sie
und ich stehe auf sie
lassen lassen
ich lasse ich ließ ich habe gelassen
ich habe meine brille zu hause gelassen
machen machen
ich mache ich machte ich habe gemacht
wir machen jetzt eine kurze pause
ich mache meine yoga übungen
was macht die klasse von herrn weiss
[Musik]
gehen gehen
ich gehe ich ging ich bin gegangen
gehst du mit mir ins kino
ich habe ich nicht gefragt
kommen kommen
ich komme ich kam
ich bin gekommen ich komme ich kam
ich bin gekommen
jetzt kommt die top ten
na endlich
geben geben
ich gebe ich gab
ich habe gegeben ich gebe ich gab
ich habe gegeben
ich gebe spannenden unterricht
ich gebe spannenden unterricht wollen
wollen
ich will ich wollte ich habe gewollt
ich will ein eis
[Musik]
sollen sollen
ich soll ich sollte ich habe gesagt ich
soll
ich sollte ich habe gesagt
ich sollte nicht so viel zucker essen
sehen ziehen
ich sehe ich sah ich habe gesehen
ich sehe nichts hinter diesem großen
mann
ich sehe schon wieder nichts hinter
diesem großen wand
müssen müssen
ich muss ich musste ich habe gewusst ich
muss ich musste ich habe gewusst
ich muss aufs wc
kannst du nicht bis zur pause warten
zu spät ich musste aufs wc
sagen sagen
ich sage ich sagte ich habe gesagt ich
sage ich sagte ich habe gesagt
ich sage dir nicht welches werk after
nummer eins ist
ich sage dir nicht welches verkauf der
können können
ich kann ich konnte ich habe gekonnt ich
kann ich konnte ich habe gekonnt
ich kann alles werden
auch du kannst alles werden
werden werden
ich werde ich wurde
ich bin geworden ich werde ich wurde
ich bin geworden
wenn ich groß bin werde ich präsident
haben haben
ich habe ich hatte
ich habe gehabt ich habe ich hatte
ich habe gehabt
ich habe genug ich habe genug
nur noch 1
und das häufig
bewerb in deutschen texten ist
sein sein
ich bin ich war ich bin gewesen
jetzt bin ich geschafft
gratuliere die haben es geschafft
gratuliere wir haben es geschafft
[Musik]
gratulation
gratulation www.hhl.de punkt ch
da brauchst du dich dann drücke hier
gleicke das video und abonniere den
kanal
vielen dank
[Musik]